good morning coach how are you Danny how
are you that was an excellent excellent
song right there we need we need to get
that online so I can get the entire
version that was perfect okay can you do
a meet Friday song for us are you
allowed to contractually with CBS you
know I I don't have one for you but I've
got one in the works that I'm saving
hopefully to debut next year with you
when football rolls around again you've
heard the song hallelujah yeah that was
Leonard and Leonard Cohen and exactly
we're gonna get for all those people who
have been jobbed by the officials
oh they screw yeah they screw yeah yeah
we're good we're gonna have that all set
to go with some of the famous screw jobs
in the history of the striped shirt all
right well good we look forward to that
let me start with what where do you want
to start you want to start with coaching
hires you wanna start with Trevor Lauren
just like to be you where would you like
to begin Trevor Lawrence is an excellent
place okay as we go back to week four of
the regular season
Dabo Sweeney's got Kelly Bryan in tow
Kelly Bryant's and you know for all
intents and purposes an outstanding
quarterback went took his team to the
playoff the year before but in that game
against Alabama in the Sugar Bowl a year
ago he went 16 of 37 for a hundred and
twenty four yards and juxtapose that
against the deshaun Watson performances
against that same Crimson Tide defense
and DeSean had over 40 yards I think
throwing in each of them so I think
Dabba looked around at the landscape of
college before what doing Haskins was
doing at Ohio State what tool was doing
in in Tuscaloosa and said I gotta put
this guy in I can't wait
this guy has to be ready to go and now
we fast forward to what do we just saw
and it was the 300 and what 47 yard
performance yeah and it was a beat down
to go along with obviously a great
defensive performance and a great
defensive game plan by Brent Venables
but Trevor Lawrence is going to be the
first pick in the draft it's just which
draft
because he is a 6/6 monster that
basically threw Clemson to the national
championship if you had the number one
pick this year but you could only have
Trevor Lawrence you'd have to wait two
more years would somebody take Trevor
Lawrence now knowing they couldn't have
him until two more years it depends on
what you would think about Dewayne
Haskins
but if Dewayne Haskins you decided he
wasn't what you wanted then absolutely I
would take Trevor Lawrence and wait
because that guy has a beautiful
throwing motion he stands tall in the
pocket
he's certainly athletic enough that last
drive they didn't I think well through
one pass and took ten minutes off the
clock and he steamrolled people for
first down so I I think the guy is a is
defined defines and and the person
wondering what the heck happened to me
is Justin Fields who now is transferring
to a Hyundai that take over for Dwayne
Haskins because he was ranked the number
one quarterback in the land and Lawrence
was number two yeah but at that position
there's not a can't-miss kid though Rick
you're right you're right I mean you has
to be system it has to be personality
and so forth but for whatever reason
Trevor Lawrence blossomed right before
our eyes and I gives all the credit in
the world the dad was Sweeney for having
the foresight to know he needed to do it
and forgetting the guy coached up to the
point where he became that fast a study
and in that kind of performance but we
also want what we can't have and you
can't have Trevor Lawrence so therefore
you know we've seen you can't get the
car you want so you really want it you
know you can't have the girl that you
really want Trevor Lawrence is he's the
object you can't have therefore we want
to have it even more the Unicorn yeah
the unique guy but there's I mean if
this was the year a point guard offense
in college football
Tunde by llola you know if we if we make
it if they make a few of those third
downs we're talking about Tonka by llola
in the same breath I mean they just went
down there and installed and in the red
zone what three or four
times in the second half so I think he's
a remarkable player
I think there's Hoskins had that kind of
year Ian's book provided that kind of
spark for Notre Dame they just don't
have the same Justin Ross's and T
Higgins and Devante Smith's and Henry
rugs that these others do talking to
Rick Neuheisel CBS sports college
football analyst joining us Continental
Tire Coach's Corner if the money was
equal and I said rank these job openings
right now the Bengals Browns Jets
dolphins Oh
III would I love Baker Mayfield
but I also love Sam Donald so I think I
would go with the Jets
III think the Jets is the best one right
there I think Cleveland would just
because it's New York they're they're
dying for a winner I believe that
there's some pieces in place defensively
that give you some hope
Cleveland certainly has those same
pieces I just think sometimes the
Cleveland organization gets in the way
in terms of some of the you know the
moves that we look back now on and say
what were they thinking right there you
know but ultimately if you ask me to
rank and you did I'm going with the Jets
as but number one okay Donald so Jets
Browns and then Bengals and dolphins and
then I actually yeah I would go bangles
and dolphins I I would I think you've
got it right there did the Cardinals
make the right choice in Kliff Kingsbury
as head coach you know what give cliff
all the credit in the world because he
has produced some epic signal callers
now he didn't coach Baker Mayfield to
the finish line but he had him he had
mahomes and he's also had Davis Webb all
three of those guys are in the lake and
two of the three are making headlines so
people are looking around saying you
know who's the next chammak Bay and
here's Kliff Kingsbury a handsome kid
that you know has done great things
offensively you talked to defensive
coaches in the big 12 they all say he's
the real deal
I understand it now
just have to pair him with the defensive
coordinator that he can hand the keys to
that side of the ball up and then go to
work but Kingsbury and and Josh Rosen I
think is going to an interesting comfort
combination and I look forward to
watching it now but he didn't win at
Texas Tech and he had Patrick Mahoney
you know so I I just I didn't see the
jump from you got fired at Texas Tech
you you stopped by USC to visit the
campus and now you're the head coach in
Arizona when I could have made him the
offensive coordinator or you know I
would have insisted that my whoever I'm
hiring as a head coach bring him in as
the offensive coordinator but head coach
is big that's a big jump man big jump it
is a big jump I'm anxious to see how it
works in the team that really gets in a
bind is SC because now I think clay
Helton has to stay with that particular
style of offense you know it's hard for
him to go just go get another name
coordinator because now it looks as if
the only higher the name he was thinking
that was the system he needed to be in
to be successful everybody can
understand but that means he has to hire
that system again and where is he going
is that it's it's an interesting
conundrum now for clay especially given
all the recruits that signed up to be
part of air raid you know
Southern California and and now he's got
to find another heir a guy interesting
dilemma I just don't know why Kingsbury
signed with USA when you know if your
goal is to coach in the NFL as an
assistant or as a head coach like why go
to USC and because if you do well then
clay Helton keeps his job so you're not
even getting the head coaching job at
USC right but you know he's he's a guy
that maybe wanted to just get back to
the offensive side of the ball maybe
ultimately as we've seen because he took
the job in the NFL that was the ultimate
goal and to prove that he had the chops
to to take a big time program back to a
mantle that they so desperately crave is
you and I know about USC so I understand
the lore of that particular job and that
particular
grande it's it's it's a got everybody's
eyes wide open in the football coaching
world that he got he took getting fired
from Texas Tech to a job in the NFL
usually it takes a 10 or 11 season to
get that kind of notice but we're in in
a world of trickle up football meaning
think of all the high school coaches
that now have big multi-million dollar
deals at at the collegiate level right
the Gus Malzahn right who went through
from Springdale Arkansas it went all the
way up and I was making 49 million bucks
and the same thing is happening because
we took that little offense our trials
was a high school coach and took his
offense to college
you you saw all these moves and now the
college offenses are moved making their
way to the NFL and everybody's going I
need to get one of those right I need
one of that as fancy cars and Kingsbury
represents that what about Bruce Arians
who said he was done and I know that you
guys are lifers like if somebody called
you you know you're coaching right now
so yeah I'm sure there's probably room
for us to play but Bruce Arians was done
yeah you know he must not have liked the
broadcaster's you must not like it but
you know what it is you guys are control
freaks and then all of a sudden you sit
around you go I I don't have anything to
do right yeah well obviously he couldn't
hit it down the middle you know playing
a heavy fade it just got all foreign
playing from the rough from the trees
from the traps so he just said let me
get a whistle again but I'm certainly
I'm certain that they're going to be a
bunch of old coach is going to be doing
in that troop again and good for Tampa
Bay good a visit with you we'll wait for
that song and thanks for joining us as
always coach that's rick neuheisel
former college coach now working for CBS
coaching me Arizona hotshots Continental
Tire coaches corner proud to be the
exclusive tire of the Dan Patrick show
no matter where you drive how you drive
what you drive continental designs
Turner's for what you do for more
information visit Continental Tire calm
for what you do for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]